[Musique]
d'un bout à l'autre du pays l'industrie
touristique se prépare à une bonne
saison estivale enfin mais après les
restrictions sanitaires il ya quand même
d'autres obstacles qui se dressent sur
la route de la relance est
principalement c'est le manque de main
d'oeuvre dont on parle souvent avec nous
ce soir pour en parler l'isaf rue la
présidente du conseil d'administration
de destination canada bonsoir bonsoir
mon ça j'allais vous êtes aussi bien sûr
directeur général de l'institut de
tourisme et d'hôtellerie du québec mais
comme présidente de destination canada
vous vous baladez au canada de ce temps
ci pour vérifier l'état des lieux quel
est l'état de santé de l'industrie
touristique alors qu'on amorce en
quelque sorte la relance c'est plus
encourageant je dois dire la semaine
dernière c'était rendez vous rendez vous
au canada c'est une grande foire
touristique international organisé par
des stages au canada et l'on s'aperçoit
que oui c'est plus encourageant malgré
que la reprise beaucoup plus forte si la
main d'oeuvre et de leur bonnet blanc
malgré que une augmentation de main
d'oeuvre c'est ce qu'il faut comprendre
s'ils sont sauf qu'on ne dit pas assez
souvent c'est une industrie de 106
points 1 milliard soit en 2019
aujourd'hui on est rendu à 53 points et
58 points et 3 milliards dont il ya eu
il ya eu vraiment
qui a été très très très très touché par
la pandémie par contre par contre on est
quand même mieux que l'année passée et
on s'aperçoit qu'une croissance qu'on
s'aperçoit aussi c'est que les gens on
veut sortir on les a fait sortir les
touristes sont de retour absolument mais
est-ce qu'on est ce qu'on revient à 100%
capacité est ce qu'on est en train en
2022 de revenir au niveau de 2019 c'est
à dire que on on prédit qu'en 20-25 on
sera autour de 2019 foulon pop up et si
non plus parce qu aux etats unis le sont
venus comme avant c'est jusqu'à nous la
pénurie mais de faire en sorte que quand
on dit exemple les hôtels sont pleins
oui les hôtels sont pleins mais il est
possible qu'un étage complet de fermer
les stores ans a été la même chose la
restauration c'est moins 24% alors en
termes de de
demain doivent alors il faut quand même
faire le plein
dis donc c'est beaucoup cette mais
développe qui manque et on parle quand
même d'une mais doivent écouter les lits
chauds sont astronomiques à sa main
d'oeuvre en 2019 c'était 696 1400
emplois aujourd'hui on est à
498 1500 emplois parce que l'équipe
gagne il fait l'activité économique n'a
pas repris ou parce qu'ils manquent de
mes demandes main d'oeuvre y manque de
main d'oeuvre soit 200000 personnes à
trois points à trois points 9 % à peu
près le du taux de chômage tout le monde
se bat pour ce bassin de main-d'oeuvre
là par contre il y as augmentation des
sommes au québec cette année que j'ai
d'avoir les chefs leur propre toit
qu'aujourd'hui on a dix mille emplois de
plus qu'en mars
50 noeuds 1100 emplois de plus qu'il ya
un an donc la main d'oeuvre
tranquillement revient maintenant moi
évidemment je dirige et thq alors je
parle d'une main d'oeuvre qui se doit
d'être formés parce que parallèlement ça
les prix augmentent le poste à l'est du
congo mais les prix augmentent partout
et c'est normal tu es le panier
d'épicerie augmenté de 19 pour ça vous
l'avez dit ici ensuite la même chose
aussi au niveau des bains de l'es6 donc
toute la question de décence donc
libellés les prix des billets d'alias je
vous emmener sur les travailleurs
étrangers temporaires c'est quand même
important dans l'industrie touristique
de l'hébergement et du tourisme au sens
large ce droit est ce que
l'administration comment vous n'y avez
pas trop ce à dire que comme si exemple
la saisonnalité dont une à la
saisonnalité ça veut bien en agriculture
on fait venir des travailleurs et il
repart donc travailleurs temporaires
pour une certaine période
oui
ça en tourisme on n'est pas sur la liste
on n'y a pas d'eau et vous voudriez d'un
secteur du tourisme à soi ça s'arrête
oui parce qu'il y en a plusieurs qui
nous manque travers juste travailleurs
temporaires pour
l'entretien donc cette main d'oeuvre qui
manquent parce que les autres
travailleurs qui se doivent eux d'être
bien formé parce qu'on dit encore qu'il
manque 36000 canada la 36 e mails
dont parle de management donc des dégâts
le cadre des gestionnaires puis en asie
on va perdre aussi tout le savoir du
tourisme le savoir de l'accueil alors ça
aussi c'est important le niveau de la
formation 10 dans l'accueil il y a les
aéroports il y à de longues files ça
fait quelques jours ou quelques semaines
dont on parle des filets longues files
les gens doivent attendre longtemps il
ya il ya l'association du transport
aérien international qui estime que le
problème affectant en ce moment cent
mille passagers par semaine à cause de
quoi problème il y en a beaucoup c'est
deux choses là bas ils y arrivent canada
va falloir cannes alors cette
application là où des souvent ce qui
arrive c'est ce qu'ils connaissent
arrive quand devons remplir davance mais
ceux qui ne tenait ce pari fiennes ou
encore même aux frontières aux
frontières terrestres
les américains savent peau le tout à
coup sont obligés la demande de remplir
arrive quand ils sont sur place les
autres attendent l'envers ensuite il y a
aussi le manque de main d'oeuvre au
bailliage alors ça affecte tous là par
contre par contre ya une question de
logistique t on apprend vive avec ça on
apprend à composer je dis pas que demain
matin ceux qui aujourd'hui prend deux
heures belle votre église jour au
lendemain mais
s'attarder sur la logistique pourrait
aider à diminuer son veulent attendre le
temps d'arrêt ce que ça nuit
au tourisme à la reprise du tourisme ou
c'est des problèmes logistiques pour mot
vivre avec les problèmes logistiques on
est prêts à faire les files d'attentes
en face il ya deux choses les problèmes
logistiques va falloir se dire oui ça va
être plus long puis tu t'en vas là les
rapports baisse plus deux hommes est en
c3 maintenant ces problèmes logistiques
l'os est partout moi j'ai une amie qui
revient de paris qui était le parent
affaires père m'a dit moi je voulais
prendre ça calmement je me suis rendu 4
jacques à la rue à paris charles de
gaulle quatre heures avant pas de j'en
ai eu besoin alors un moment donné ça
veut voyager si sûr qu' il peut y avoir
une problématique donc moi je conseille
la très grande patience ou sinon on
voyage intra à rabat lors ils auront
voyagé tra on voyage on découvre notre
canada qui a tout à offrir vraiment sur
ces paroles disent aux fruits la merci
des recettes les sésames pour voir nos
émissions en entier rendez vous sur la
chaîne ici et redit